I'm wearing a fancy black and white
outfit just like the guys and just like
them we're getting trashed just kidding
but it is time for roses and roses eh
hi you guys i'm lauren zima thank you so
much for joining us here is we
Bachelorette recap Becca Cooper in
season episode two we're back in the
studio today Wow a pink wall I love it
and a pink drink I love that more yeah
this is one of my favorite brands of
Rose Day but I can't say which one it is
because they don't sponsor us someone
sponsor me
I need free wine so we open up with
Becca doing a lot of bike riding I don't
know why they show her in Venice and if
you don't know the Los Angeles area that
is very far from the location of the
mansion she didn't bike ride to the
mansion guys but you know let's get our
steps in and then we've got the first
group date and Becca it's harkening it
back to the past so when she was
pampered by Ari which we were on the set
of by the way shameless blog that might
be our first ever throwback shameless
plug oh I just said Ari's named in mine
try not to don't try this at home guys
this is done by professionals so Becca
because she was pampered on her first
one-on-one date wants to pamper her guys
on the first group date so she puts them
on these amazing black and white tuxedos
only to have them trash the tuxedos now
they're gonna do a freaking obstacle
course and get these beautiful tuxedos
all muddy and disgusting I'm not down
for this do you know how hard it is to
get a modern man to dress well okay this
is the 1900s guys aren't out there
sporting pocket squares on the daily
we're gonna just throw these suits to
the mud whatever anyway we agree to
disagree
get over your exes but reach one Brian
are there and I love that because we
love Rachel and Brian seems to love
Rachel and so I love Brian I support
women anyway so these guys have to get
in cold water and man are they why me
about it try giving birth again I
support women not that I've given birth
but I've heard it's difficult my main
focuses please way to Wayne Wayne I
don't know what happened with this
contest they had some very rudimentary
timers and everyone seemed to think
Lincoln cheated but let's be honest that
system wasn't foolproof so Lincoln won I
guess we ought to go long a great you
trashed your suit the best mmm now we go
to the late night date night portion of
the group date and Becca looks amazing
in this red lace thing her style is on
point
shout out to Carrie sentiment stylist of
the show follow him on Instagram I'm a
big fan anyway so I'm going to ignore
all of the guys going on and on about
how Lincoln got to steal her away first
like let's move forward from these
tropes okay I don't need these moments
but we have to fill two hours and Becca
sits down with Lincoln first and her
hair looks great God she looks good a
flat iron happened there and I'm not
usually okay with it anyway I don't know
anyone's name at this point but there's
a blonde guy who says Lincoln always has
to have the last word he's kind of cute
we'll see if he sticks around and Becca
gives Lincoln a picture of them and he
says that she's quote so beautiful
so clean and beautiful was this weird to
anyone else I'm gonna get that he's
dirty but like I don't ever need a guy
to tell me I looks so clean weird okay
Becca and Lincoln kiss and you know
what's tough is when on a first kiss
somebody speed is too fast too soon you
know take it slow don't just dive right
in too much
is like flying to the moon on the wings
of a Pegasus what come back down
no one ever say that Lincoln you're
turning me off right now I don't want
you to tell me I'm clean or that you're
on the wings of a Pegasus Oh and then he
adds Dancing with unicorns on the pot of
gold that's what it's about
how many fairytale mythical moments are
we having during this kiss Lincoln I
don't even believe you anyways the guys
keep saying that Lincoln is dangling the
photo in their faces so drink every time
they say that dangle dangle dangle
dangle and dangle dangling in front of
our faces you know you can't even dangle
a photo and then one guy whose name I
don't know says he's over it and he
throws it in the pool in the pool and
here's my issue
California's a drought state and if that
glass cracked that means they've got to
drain that pool for safety reasons and
that's just irresponsible so I'd send
him home just for that the environment
that's why I drink Rosie I'm just saving
the water for the people father you gave
me Lincoln tells Becca and buy Lincoln
tattling we learned that the guy's name
is Connor and again we're talking about
how the photo was being dangled dangling
in front of our faces and then Lincoln
just really has a meltdown about how
important this photo was for him because
Becca was so clean I feel like there's
more to this story did he have some kind
of traumatic incidents in the past I
don't know then we have the first
one-on-one date and it's time for a very
big shameless plug ET was exclusively on
the set for this one-on-one date you
guys can check out the behind the scenes
of ET online.com and what a date it was
Blake gets the first one-on-one date
which doesn't surprise me because she
said that they were quote on the same
wavelength
and let's remember that Becca was ours
first one-on-one date and any picture
interesting and if you're gonna move
forward and find love here and look to
the future you have to deal with the
past this warehouse is full of re stuff
and you guys you can get all the behind
the scenes at ET online.com shameless
plug and i have to say that in person i
was blown away by this date on the one
hand we
you know because you are on a date with
someone and you're gonna spend the whole
date smashing memories of their past
relationship with someone else like
that's weird but also we know what Becca
went through with Arie and this was my
favorite part the gray couch I find it
incredibly ironic that in our news set
we have a great couch how many times did
we see that gray couch in the promos for
Becca and re-split and they smashed up
the gray couch I loved it so much I gave
the producers all my compliments and Lil
Jon was there and a little inside tip
they'd been wanting a little John to
come on the show for quite some time and
this was the moment for it to happen
props to the editors here because the
editing is amazing as bleak and Becca
smash everything up they go slo-mo they
said to Lil Jon song and they smash the
past
wow that felt great
felt good for JC 200 it also felt good
for Becca and Blake and again you can
get our interviews with them in detail
like that comment mm-hmm I also want to
point out that Becca says Blake is great
because he's very different than Ari and
in an interview with me she said her
fiance is quote very different than Ari
just saying mm-hmm you have to get more
down and dirty and open up a lot quicker
so then Blake and Becca go to dinner and
I love this Becca told Blake this
process works when you open up real
quick
great like just set the stage for him
tell him you need to get down and dirty
real fast because we have about you know
30 minutes to get to know each other I
appreciated that she said that great
bachelor etting Becca yes big and Blake
says that everything with her just feels
natural and I like Blake because
remember how unnatural everything with
Ari and Lauren felt there's a lot of
silence
I hate silence anyway so blake is great
then is another group date and they
greet back off of the bus and concept
she smells even better somehow he means
that not weird that was cute and these
kids these kids are going to teach
something to play dodgeball and man are
these little kids great the little girl
yells and a little boy calls the ball I
just love them at these these child
actors I'm so in now we're the
championship of the dodgeball game
because you know let's cut to that and
Fred Willard is back I love Fred Willard
he was on who shall not be names season
announcing the dog show and now he's
back and he's so funny and of course
with dodgeball we're gonna have a lot of
balls jokes aren't we yep mmm drink
every time or don't because you got to
be safe so the game is being played and
we get more slow-mo so much slow-mo this
season episode but I'm exhausted for
more slow-mo great and Leo is really
killing it looking sexy during this and
I'm not a big sports fan so back to the
nighttime parts of this date Becca talks
to Garrett near an indoor pool they seem
to have a great conversation but I can't
stop thinking about how indoor pools
have like that really strong chlorine II
smell and I've taken back to my
childhood like the occasions of my
family and that chlorine smell and
there's nothing sexy about it so I'd
rather smell something else anyway and
Colton reveals Bom Bom Bom
there's something that Becca doesn't
know about me that I need her to know he
dated TF gray t of course is Becca's
friend from re-season also we got quotes
from buck on that and you can check the
buddy channel my confidence Becca says
I'm not gonna lie she's upset about it
don't drink every time Becca says that
she's not gonna lie this episode
like you I'm not gonna lie I'm not gonna
lie because she said it and some of the
guys said it quite a lot mmm
anyway so Becca questions cold not gonna
lie I don't blame ya and she gives the
rose to wills I don't know who that is
but wills will you accept this rose as a
kind of I'm not gonna lie
ok back to the mansion for the cocktail
party and rose ceremony Becca dresses
all the guys and the clay is teaching
her a touchdown dance and Wow would this
be my worst nightmare to have to catch a
football and then do a touchdown dance
and then kiss someone no thanks I think
you guys let me know how you feel in the
comments on a date with someone
are you into them teaching you what
they're into or do you want to be like
ask more questions about yourself
I'm the latter but am I being too harsh
let me know in the comments thank you I
love your thoughts always slow-mo wink
[Music]
anyway okay so I've got to give props to
Connor here
Connor looked like an idiot with this
throwing the Lincoln photo thing so he
totally owned it and I had Becca throw a
photo of him and this guy here he just
looks like an idiot
applause for Connor I suddenly like you
that's how quickly things can change in
this game you guys it's about owning
your mistakes own it that's the biggest
rule for anybody on any reality show you
know I think that we can the male model
he's back and he decides that he doesn't
want to be like every other student
house there's a lot to me I'm really
wild very spontaneous we have chiseled
ABS and stunning features remember he
loves a gray suit and he loves a unique
suit so he's gonna go down to his
birthday suit and just walk around his
boxers and he says quote nothing
attracts a woman more nothing attracts a
woman more than like being comfortable
next to a sexy man what what what I
don't know that means Jordan let me know
in the comments also do you guys believe
that Jordan really believes this stuff I
did an interview with ABC executive
Robert Mills and he says this is Jordans
truth let me know if you think it is
anyway so now back to Colton and Becca
says she is so torn on Colton and let's
say for Becca what Beck I can't say
she's very attracted to Colton it's
weird that he dated her friend but she
thinks he's easy on the eyes so she
doesn't want to send him home
and she keeps them during the rose
ceremony great good call Becca you do
you girl you deserve that deserve that
cool let me seems like a nice guy
anyways so let me know what you guys
think of Colt do you think he's there
for the right reasons
oh god I gotta stuff up and get myself
wrinkles so we are at the rose ceremony
and we're saying goodbye to some guys
and I don't recognize any of them or
know any of their names and they are
gone
bye thanks for playing also oh wow
messing up my own set here a couple
glasses in also I know everyone was so
upset to see grocery store Joe go home
that went viral after the premiere so
you guys guess what guess what I got an
exclusive interview with the grocery
store Joe
somebody's here like I asked him his
favorite snacks and we love snacks and
we love Joe he's a snack anyway so thank
you guys so much for being here please
let me know what you think of how this
season is going there's a lot to talk
about Garrett's Instagram scandal yes it
must be addressed
I got quotes from Becca on it I got
quotes from an ABC exact Robert nose on
it that's all uppity t online calm and
then Garrett himself acknowledged it
finally and I want to know what you guys
think of his apology was it enough did
he say what you needed him to say and
who do you think Becca's frontrunners
are at this point now that we've had a
first impression rose and a one-on-one
date let me know and also check out our
Facebook discussion group where we talk
about the Bachelorette every single
Monday night and I love you guys thank
you so much for being here there's
nothing else to say except that I still
have wine in my glass so a slow-motion
finish feels appropriate
thanks everybody and have a great week
bye
[Music]